this is Grandmaster Daniel nitzki we are
watching Magnus Carlson taking on Maxim
vagra the Frenchman with three names in
their match at the 2023 Champions
Chester finals and Magnus Carlson
starting the game with a ready opening
one night F3 Magnus of forest can play
Everything equally well and on the
second move he plays kind of a reverse
Bon with C4 and Maxim trying to decide
which direction he's going to take this
game in the principled move is D4 that
leads to a reverse Bon setup Maxim he
plays a queen gam but declined E6 is on
the board now Maxim is typically a
grunfeld player so maybe Magnus is
trying to take his opponent out of his
comfort zone G3 Magnus Fen ketoing his
Bishop playing this like in English
Maxim continues to develop his King side
Bishop B7 now D4 would transpose into a
Catalan but it seems to me that Magnus
is trying to keep the spirit of the
position alive the move B3 here is more
typical for English players so B3 is
possible D4 leads to a Mainline Catalin
Magnus taking his time making this
important opening
decision and let's see what Carlson
decides he continues to ponder his move
and there it is and indeed he has played
the move B3 preparing to fian ketto his
second Bishop double fian ketto setups
are always so interesting but they can
be very risky because white concedes a
pretty large share of the center the
principled response for black is now to
push that D Pawn up to D4 and then to
secure it with the c Pawn D4 followed by
C5 and that is exactly what Maxim does
he is one of the most principal players
out there Magnus Carlson will he fto the
bishop no he will immediately contest
Black Center with E3 now Maxim he is
unlikely to capture on E3 he will want
to maintain his control over the center
instead he plays the move Knight to C6
Magnus Carlson seems to be caught a
little bit by surprise the more standard
reaction would have been to start with
C5 and then to follow up with Knight C6
and Carlson trades on D4 a lot of
tension in the center Fen King the
second Bishop Magnus Carlson attacking
the Knight on D4 and if Maxim will not
maintain his strangle hold on the D4
square and the entire concept with
Knight C6 will turn out to be very
dubious that Bishop on C8 is also
blocked in by the pawn on E6 Maxim's
Queens side is under some fire and he's
trying his best and let's see what
Magnus decides now he can take twice on
D4 Black's Queen will ultimately land on
D4 and the Queen is a very vulnerable
piece so Magnus deciding does he want to
take on D4 no he leaves the Knight
exactly where it is and instead he
completes his development this is a very
typical Magnus move he tosses the ball
back into Black's court and the knight
from C3 can also potentially jump to A4
hitting the bishop on C5 and introducing
an element of Discord into Black's
position now Maxim he can develop his
light squared Bishop to D7 but that
looks like a very awkward move indeed
the knight from F3
it can also jump into E5 opening up the
diagonal for the G2 Bishop Rook to E8 is
Maxim's Choice Magnus Carlson
uncomfortable with the kind of position
that he has reached my inclination would
be to play Knight to E5 here because
that would make it very difficult for
black to open up the diagonal for the
bishop and Magnus he follows the
commentator's advice a big mistake
Knight E5 is on the board and that
Knight on E5 it's a pretty Loose Cannon
it's not protect by anything but white
can bring the Rook down to E1 and that
might be necessary Maxim brings his
Bishop back to D6 that's a one move
threat obviously Magnus is not going to
move the Knight away from E5 that would
defeat the entire purpose of what he is
trying to do Rook e one looks like a
very natural move F4 instead Magnus
choosing a more aggressive option
protecting the Knight with a pawn and in
the event of a trade on E5 the pawn
would replace the Knight it would still
make it impossible for black to develop
his bishop and the f file would open up
the F7 Pawn would be incredibly
vulnerable that seems to be out of the
question has Maxim vagra misplayed this
position as he tries to establish the
Knight on D4 the bishop goes back to C5
and obviously a big threat of a
discovered check against the white king
Magnus very likely will move his King
over to H1 he can also consider
attacking that Bishop with Knight to A4
uh but these types of adventurous moves
not really magnus's style in a rapid
Game King H1 seems very safe he plays it
and Max he's been kind of moving back
and forth he still hasn't solved the
problem of his Queen side and now the
Knight on E5 is firmly entrenched it's
protected beautifully by The Pawn on F4
magnus's King is completely safe and a
little hesitation there from the
Frenchman he was about to play Queen D6
he didn't like something about that move
maybe it was that Knight A4 move that I
had talked about earlier hitting the
bishop on C5 Maxim has only two feasible
Queen moves you can play Queen E7 he can
play Queen D6 neither of those moves
seems particularly attractive he does
decide on Queen E7 so changes his mind
about his move remember that unless a
piece has been released you do not have
to move the piece to that square you
have to move that piece because it's
touch move but you can move it to a
different Square now Knight A4 looks
really juicy here but Magnus plays on
the other side of the board G4 and down
goes White's Pawn Magnus says I'm
castled to the king side I don't care
the King on H1 is completely safe it's
protected the bishop on G2 and the pawn
on H2 and the f and g pawns they are
tasked with shattering Black's own King
side that pawn is going to move into G5
and it's going to open up the E4 Square
for White's Knight that will be a
catastrophe for Black's Bishop on C5
Black's position is on the verge of
crumbling Maxim he prepares for the
apocalypse with a move Rook to d8 adding
another Defender to the D4 Knight but
down goes magnus's Pawn up to G5 it goes
forcing the Knight back to D7 and now
the E4 square has been carved out for
for White's Knight Knight to E4 is going
to attack the bishop on C5 it's going to
open up the diagonal for White's dark
scored bishop and this game might end in
Checkmate on the king side the queen
from D1 is begging it's begging to be
placed on H5 where it will participate
in the attack Magnus Carlson centralizes
his other night 94 is on the board and
Maxim vash's Central campaign has
resulted in complete an abject failure
he still has not developed his Queen
side he's playing this entire game
without the use of his Bishop without
the use of his Rook on A8 and Magnus
Carlson's pieces his Bishops in
particular are operating in a beautiful
Symphony of strength Knight to f8 mvl
says I'm not going down without a fight
the Knight drops back for defensive
purposes it can probably be rerouted up
to G6 Maxim would do very very well to
get rid of at the very least one of
Magnus Carlson's Knights which are
currently terrorizing black on both
sides of the board and some important
decisions here for Magnus Carlson he
could take the bishop on C5 and grab the
bishop pair and cash in his chips but he
says no I am going for more than that
the queen joins the attack Queen to H5
is on the board now the direct threat is
Knight takes C5 and queen takes F7 check
Black's Queen is going to be overloaded
Maxim might have to play Knight G6 that
was his idea with Knight f8 and he plays
it the Knight on G6 a very good Defender
and Magnus you can just sense he's
looking for the kill shot he's looking
for the killer blow he can still take
the bishop on C5 but the knight from E5
can also Retreat down to G4 and what a
move by Magnus threatening Knight F6
check that Knight is going to sacrifice
itself on F6 and Black's King is going
to be massacred by the combined forces
of White's Queen and White's other
Knight Knight F6 check is a devastating
threat the bishop on B2 will also join
in the attack Maxim is busted here he
has no moves he tries to whip up some
counterplay desperately with Bishop to
A3 and he might eliminate White's Bishop
but I think White's Knights and White's
Queen are more than capable of carrying
the load and Magnus still looking for
that kill shot is it time for Knight G
or Knight E to F6 check that seems to
work very nicely Knight F6 check if
black takes the Knight then white can
take back on F6 maybe Maxi wants to
sacrifice the queen on F6 for three
pieces that might be what Magnus is
contemplating move 19 Magnus already on
the cusp of Checkmate and there it is
Knight F6 check Knight is sacrificed and
Magnus recaptures with the pawn that is
the subtlety he takes with the pawn in
order to attack Black's Queen and most
importantly to vacate the G5 Square for
his other Knight what a genius concept
by Magnus Carlson who resists the
tempting move and instead plays the
killer move and now Knight G5 Knight G5
looks like the killer move that is going
to be Checkmate ladies and gentlemen
black can defend the H7 Pawn with Knight
to f8 but then F7 will fall with mate
white can also deliver L's mate with
Queen H6 6 there it is Knight G5 on the
board Maxim he runs with the King but
there is no chance it's usin bolt racing
against a 90-year-old Rook to D7
everything is collapsing Magnus picks up
the Knight on D4 The Rook cannot capture
back and Maxim throws in the towel what
a clinical miniature by Magnus Carlson
an incredibly high quality game as he
destroys Maxima shilag grav in their
match game at the 2023 CCT finals all
smiles at the end of the and I hope this
game put a smile on your face thank you
so much for watching I hope to see you
in a subsequent
[Music]
video